well nevada has the highest unemployment
rate in the nation the u.s is about 4.2
percent right now here in nevada it's
about 7.3 percent but even while
unemployment is high there are plenty of
unfilled jobs right now and today the
state is trying to help fill them the
oklahoman live this afternoon at job
fest 2021 with a look at the state's
largest job fair hi bianca
more than 150 employers here at the
convention center ready to hire on the
spot and they've got 16 thousand open
positions
i encourage you
please join me in visiting as many
booths as you can have a great day
everybody god bless y'all let's go
thousands of jobs up for grabs and taja
newton just needs one she recently
graduated from a medical academy and
wants to be a phlebotomist it feels
awesome because i'm more in person
person anyways versus a
internet or over the phone type of
person so just be able to address in
person it makes it feel more personal
more informative job fest is nevada's
job fair it's an effort to fill the
needs of companies and non-profits
across the state for career changers or
those experiencing dead ends job connect
works one-on-one with job seekers we
also find people who have wonderful
great skills and they just need help
talking about that understanding how
those skill sets are transferable into a
new job so that they can continue to
pursue their goals in terms of
professional fulfillment while nevada
has been hit hard over the past years
unemployment in clark county is less
than half it was a year ago this job
fest is one step to help rebuild as
employers want to fill open positions
and people want to join a team that
helps them provide for their family
what's your hopes after today getting a
job
even if it's coming out of here with two
i'm fine with working two jobs just to
get everything back on track
[Music]
and of course to measure the success of
this event we spoke with organizers and
they tell us they'll keep count of those
who are hired on the spot or shortly
thereafter and also those who enroll in
training programs for those who are
seeking to change careers bianca holman
live local now
bianca thank you very much on that note
the venetian right now is looking for
workers hosting a career fair tomorrow
to work at the venetian or the palazzo
the event is from two to six the murano
ballroom if you're interested apply
online first careers.sands.com
again this is tomorrow interviews will
be conducted on site
optum nevada also hosting a job fair
tomorrow the healthcare company hiring
for a number of positions this is over
at the optum building it's antanea near
smoke ranch from 11 to 7 again that is
tomorrow